- Attendu de pied ferme,
une sellette virtuelle. Alors
que les appels à la démissionse,
du bout des lèvres.
MICHAEL BRIND'AMOUR, ancien
- Il y a encore beaucoup à faire
à Hockey Canada, et beaucoup de
travail qui aurait pu être fait
plus tôt.
- Malgré tout, Hockey Canada
se défend bec et ongles.
onds secrets
pour régler les plaintes
d'agresslles était
selon elle appropriée, les
appels à la démission, exagérés.
Hockey Canada se dit victime
d'une campagne de salissagedans,
dit-elle, le directeur
de l'organisme mérite un AL'évat
plus sévère. Ils exigeaientdes s
sur leur faim."Pouvez-vous nousn
d'argent il reste dans le fonds
pour les agressions sexuelles?"
my answer is no.
- Je vous le demande.
Êtes-vous surpris?
- Je peux pas répondre, non,
Monsieur Martel.
simple : qui est imputable à
Hockey Canada?
PETER JULIAN, député, NPD
New Westminster - Burnaby, C.-B.
- On pose des ques
C'est comme... une négligence
de préparation pour le comitépa.
RICHARD MARTEL, député,
PCC, Chiêtre obliêtre obliêtre e
les faire revenir chaque semaine
pour qu'ils comprennent qu'i
faut que les dirigeants
démissionnent?
Abitibi-Témiscamingue, Qc
- Depuis le début de l'été,
c'est scandale après scandale.
Il y en a un chaque semaine.
Là, ça suffit! Il faut faioute..
- Les partis d'opposition
veulent une enquê
indépendante. De son côté,
le gouvernement augmente
à nouveau la pres
aujourd'hui, évidemment,
c'est pa'espérais'espérais'espés
des audiences.toutes les autrese
hockey au pays, à sortir de leu.
PASCALE ST-ONGE,
ministre fédérale des Sports
membres votants qui peuvent
changer les choses à Hockey
Canada au niveau du conseil
d'administration.spendu
es leviers
du gouvernement face à Hockey
Canada sont limitén bras de fer
sur la scène de l'opinion
publique, pendant que Hockey
Canada tente de protéger
son imagistian Noël,
Radio-Canada, Ott